so an orm stands for object relational
mapping
this just means that we map sql objects
which are relational and you have you
know foreign keys and primary keys to
actual objects and code so that way we
can more easily both read and view
respond in objects and also manipulate
them so that way you can set properties
and say like save changes instead of
needing to think about okay how do i do
an update statement and sql server oh
this is a postgres table how do i do an
update statement and postgres rm
abstracts all of that it's really nice
but
i don't think they're perfect
and here we just have a little bit of a
sample of here's what a user demo table
would look like and here's what the orm
entity framework would let us operate on
so this isn't all the like boilerplate
code but this is the object that you
would actually use when you're
interacting with the database
and so yeah they make it really easy to
read document and actually talk about
our database objects that's where orms
are like the shining beacon in the sky
i don't think anyone's going to fault
them for this
it's so much better to actually deal
with these objects we can make link
queries on top of them instead of having
to do uh nitty gritty sql queries like i
had to look up the the like statement i
didn't know if it was the same in ms
sequel and postgres and they seem to be
the same thing i'm sure you guys can
tell me how i'm wrong and that they're
not actually the same query but we'll
leave that as an exercise for the reader
in the later arguments
so this is actually a live query from
one of our systems that i work out at my
job
they
you can see that that's not exactly the
most readable thing in the world if we
have an orm object we can actually just
operate on top of the object instead of
needing to see all of the sql so that's
from one routing point so at an api at
work generates all of those statements
it was difficult to get them into a
screenshot so
you'll have to forgive me for how small
it is um another thing that orms really
protect you against is sql injection uh
that that's a big problem uh for any
town who's developed an external api you
need to clean your inputs you need to
sanitize and you need to parameterize
everything orms just kind of do that as
long as you're making sure you're
following their uh the flavor of the
month or the the how the orm wants you
to do that and they all vary uh
differently but any framework i actually
uh will be posting a list of resources i
use to kind of go over this talk and any
framework is one of the better ones you
can do cleaned inputs uh and you can
even do raw parameterized queries so
if you do have to dip down into the raw
sequel whether you need to tell your
query planner like hey query planner
don't use this index or don't use this i
want you to do this you can do that in
any framework which is a key mark a very
good orm bad rms do not let you do raw
sql and that's a that's a problem also
as i was building the stock and and
doing some code samples i noticed uh
intellisense is the best like python
doesn't have anything on intellisense so
you guys definitely did something right
by picking c sharp as your career
language uh so you can always have this
beautiful autocomplete like sometimes i
just hit dot and i don't even know what
i'm looking for and i just kind of see
them all and i remember oh yeah i'm
trying to do xyz
so that was really good another thing is
the type safety this provides two-fold
things it's really for the documentation
as well as for
making it easier for your juniors your
mid-levels and even senior developers
because seniors you have like your hands
in every single thing
and it's difficult to know what you need
to be working on at the same time
so here's the ugly and i kind of alluded
to this at one of my earlier comments
is that
the code first
is is something that a lot of people
like uh here's my first hot take code
first is not the way to go
and the big reason is because no nothing
else integrates to it and you might say
well joel integrating to a code first
database is an any pattern you should
have something sending that out to a
data lake or something like that and
you're right you shouldn't be directly
reading and writing to a database that
you've built in any other application
you should always be having data
pipelines to move that data to another
spot where a new owner can operate on
that data that's a good pattern the the
rub is is that the world is not perfect
we all work at companies with many teams
and sometimes you need to just connect
to the database to get your job done
code first databases give you huge
dangers in your migration strategies
because if i need to migrate data that
takes more than a few milliseconds
i need to ensure that i can do that
without down timing my production
environment
and if i have to downtime my production
environment in order to migrate code all
database changes are going to be very
fragile we don't want that there's a
good article that talks about doing zero
downtime database deployments that i'll
send to you all i definitely recommend
that whether or not you agree or
disagree with me and i would really love
as someone who wants to fight for code
first could jump into twitch chat
because i think these are great
um
the other thing is that query planners
still run the world at your database
level uh so that i don't know if
anyone's run into this before but if
you've built a lot of indexes on a
database and you have a query with many
clauses you'll run into a fact where
sometimes your query will use the
indexes and sometimes it'll do a
sequential scan and you may actually
want the sequential scan if you've
already done something
uh let's say you have a gist injects or
a gen index something that is not
a simple text string that it can't be
just a b tree where you can do like a uh
what's the word for binary search so you
can't necessarily binary search on it
you need to have multiple passes over an
index a sequential scan might be faster
because you might be able to do it in
one single pass of the database table
obviously it falls apart if you have
billions of rows but if you have
billions of rows you shouldn't be
listening to me talk anyway you probably
should be listening to someone smarter
than me but for millions of rows tables
sequential scans can actually be faster
than many index lookups if those index
lookups have to be done
repeatedly
the other problem i find is that they
tightly couple a lot of our application
logic to the stored data um this isn't
great because now again to your
migration strategies if you need to
migrate from database a or from table a
to table b
you now have to change the code in the
database at the same time you can't
create the new data migrate the data
without the code knowing about it yet
then ensure a code over where your code
now knows about it knows about both
objects and then you deprecate one and
now you're only on the single table
right so this is the kind of the
like a four pass approach that the
article discusses for zero downtime
databases uh and when you're using orms
it's a little bit touch and go because
if you ever change the type of a column
if you ever change the name of a column
especially if you ever change a foreign
key or constraint relationship it gets
very tricky
and then also some orms again not most
but some i've seen this a lot in the
javascript world if you guys are looking
at some of the orms they make it really
hard to dip down to raw sql
and you might say well the whole point
of an orm is so i don't have to write
sql but again this is the real world the
real world is messy a lot of times and
in fact every place i've ever worked has
always had a use case for okay let's dip
down into the raw sql let's maybe entity
framework doesn't support this type of
index lookup maybe we need to do
something really dirty and treat strings
as json and then we need to operate on
that json and so we can't do that
directly in the orm maybe we have some
stored procedures that we don't want our
orm to know about there's lots of things
like that that feel a little dirty but
we still have to do them
and so this is a little example of how
to actually do a ross equal and entity
framework one thing that's important to
note
you'll see this app p1 in the screenshot
that's a parameterized query which is
awesome i will say most orms don't do
this so mad props to entity framework
for having parameterized queries in raw
sequel
um all right this is my favorite story
uh that i get to share with you all this
is about frisma which is a typescript
and javascript graphql orm
really powerful a lot of smart people
built prisma
i have a bone to pick with prisma and
here's why
so i have several things in the slide
just to break it down a little bit the
the key problem was is we had
an insert statement that needed to
insert a float so we had a float double
precision in our database
we needed to insert a value to that and
it worked great if it was this
1.234 number
but if you sent one like 1.0
something fell apart and there's really
two big reasons for that and that's
because there's a rust processor in
prisma that is actually talking to the
database not the javascript layer that
you're interacting with and part of this
is because people are smarter than me
and they built this really advanced
system to
do byte streams of queries and actually
operate on the bytes at the database
level and all the rest code handles this
the problem was in this one javascript
doesn't know what 1.0 is it just sends
one right there's no such thing as a
decimal or integer in javascript it's
just a number and so when that number
was sent to rust rust has a difference
between an integer and a decimal it read
that one and said ah you're trying to
set an integer value
so the part of the rest code that
received the value and the part of the
rest code that talked to the actual
database
didn't communicate on this
so rust receives a 1 says ah i will
encode this as a binary integer
sends it to the database code the
database code says i need to prepare an
insert statement with this parameterized
value
into this column of this name well that
column's double and that binary value
it's about to send is an integer so you
see this little sign bit exponent in
mantesa this is how floating and doubles
are represented in code uh this means it
was sending the smallest
non-zero positive integer to our
database which is about 4.9 times 10 to
the minus 324.
you could see how this might be a
problem if we go to read that value
where we thought we had just saved 1 and
now we have some number that is so close
to zero
most libraries will treat this as zero
in fact python will give you a divide by
zero exception if you have this in the
denominator of your uh divisor so don't
do this
um this is a huge problem uh prisma i
think has fixed this now in their
version uh thankfully we at work have
migrated away from it so uh no longer
our issue to deal with but this was a
huge nightmare in our production system
because who thinks to check if their
rorm is actually sending values to the
database right i never thought to check
that and this is what really burned me
from orms
here's one for all of the entity
framework and c-sharp guys
i actually don't know the answer to this
question so i would love it if you could
tell me this is a way to do a direct
join so that way let's say maybe these
weren't foreign key relationships the
entity framework knew about so you
couldn't just say dot include
and this is a really nice syntax and
when i worked in c sharp in 2016 they
didn't have this uh as beautiful of a
link syntax i felt like i had to do it
with unions and and within's and that
one's wasn't as pretty i didn't enjoy
that
so here is what we're doing is we're
joining up authors author biographies
and books
and then we create essentially a big
list that has all of that information
and you can see in that second link
expression we actually are grabbing all
of the different things
the problem here is what happens let's
say
an author has an awards and after this i
do a dot include awards and that is a
foreign key relationship
what will that actually do to our
database will it do a third join under
the hood will it do a sub query to fetch
all of that where we have an n plus one
number of results and number of queries
as we iterate through our authors
we don't actually know until we try it
and run the sql so this is where i think
unless you know what you're doing an orm
can really hide a lot of this if you're
just typing over these database objects
and you think they're objects in code
there's actually a lot of work that
database is having to do by fetching by
foreign key
deciding whether or not to do a sub
query or a join
in fact i believe any framework always
tries to do subqueries
my main point is that because the orm
makes it so easy to operate on objects
you don't necessarily know what those
objects what the database and orm had to
do to give you those objects in code
which can be good and bad the bad can be
the performance tradeoffs the good can
be this is really easy code to look at
for me to write out a database inner
join
and do all of that is fine it would look
very similar to this but now i don't
have the ability to say oh i want to
include their awards or their their
favorites or their prices right because
right here i don't have a price for any
of these books i just have book titles i
don't have a year it was written i don't
have any other metadata
and so it makes it easy to expand your
queries in entity framework but it does
make it a little scarier because you can
do a dot include or a a dot
property name and all of a sudden your
query execution goes to poop so uh you
you don't want that
so but thank you guys for